[Musique]
la polyester recyclée choix écolo ou
écho blanchiment sur les passerelles on
voit de plus en plus défiler des
vêtements de polyester recyclés ce tissu
est produit à partir de bouteilles de
plastique ce qui donne l'impression de
faire un choix écologique aujourd'hui
15% du polyester provient des bouteilles
ce procédé pollue moins que de fabriquer
du tissu à partir de matière vierge et
ça tombe bien ça coûte moins cher à
l'industrie c'est d'ailleurs peut-être
pour ça quand nous encourage à en
acheter par contre il faut savoir une
chose on dit que le plastique se recycle
presque à l'infini ça c'est vrai
lorsqu'une bouteille est recyclée en une
nouvelle bouteille mais quand elle sert
à faire du polyester elle n'est plus
recyclable donc une fois passé de mode
ce joli chemisier fleuri aboutira au
dépotoir et la bouteille qui aura servi
à le fabriquer sera éjectée du cycle de
l'économie circulaire c'est un problème
pour lequel l'industrie n'a toujours pas
trouvé de solution à grande échelle
alors le polyester recyclé choix écolo
ou écho blanchiment le débat est lancé
et il sera déchire
[Musique]